hi guys I'm going to do a video net long
Safari for Windows ah this is okay first
of all Internet Explorer right Internet
Explorer 7 I know that the IE 8 beta
just came out and it's supposedly much
better but who wants to bother waiting
for for Internet Explorer II WebKit to
open ok let's try
youtube.com just to see speed wise it's
kind as slow as you can see I don't even
feel like wooden takes it out I am using
Safari for what the hell okay Safari for
Windows oh I know what that was that was
a cookie for Google calm because it
infects Internet Explorer so easily so
Safari this is what I'm using now you
can see I have the arrow theme I'll do a
tutorial on get the Eowyn Safari but
when you first download it from Apple
calm here I'll show you where to get it
let's see Apple and it's already do so
this isn't going to be a snappy but also
get YouTube HD all three loading at the
same time it's already loading faster so
go to Apple downloads tab this is how to
get Safari by the way you go to the
download app and so if YouTube HD is
downloading so yeah my videos so Apple
downloads and go over here to all now go
to Safari version 3.2 Mac or PC the
world's best browser you get the
download link and it will begin loading
page oh yeah check out iTunes 8 it's
great sleep um why you love Safari is
incredibly fast like unbelievably fast
probably there are some plugins and
add-ons for it it's pretty cool download
it now it'll pop up a window you can say
I want a little fart or I want to
download Safari and QuickTime this is
for Windows because it already knows
you're on Windows not a Mac
you would have already had Safari on a
Mac so um I hit the download Safari
button oh we might have a snow day
tomorrow and download Safari now
obviously a polite easy for you to you
know the user interface is quite simple
for you to go ahead and install it so I
will let you do that on your own once
you get it ah you'll get a little Apple
Safari thing on your desktop and I set
it as my default internet browser so I'm
going to open up a new window it opens
up faster than firefox faster than
Internet Explorer Basilan flock faster
than opera it's the fastest internet
browser I have using windows now I have
used Chrome and I am salted for security
reasons but it is they are comparable in
speed I have to say Chrome or Safari
leave your comments so I'm not sure but
I like Safari just because of how simple
it is like Inquisitor II just like that
I feel in private browsing just like
that I can go empty cache it just like
that I can bookmark something just
really quickly check my gmail just like
that so uh uh it's it's definitely a
significant improvement over internet
explorer if you're still using Internet
Explorer I highly suggest you upgrade to
either filer Firefox or Safari um but I
opera is decent now let me show you the
asset three problems in so far um
everyone else what they asked three
tests it will it has to get to a hundred
out of a hundred to pass look at that 74
out of 100 because the link test failed
now if I were to open opera 10 which
does take a good long while to load you
will see the acid3 test is much higher
despite the lack of speed of opera 10 so
let's see s3 5000 three
he knows a loading book and click on
that and it'll test your browser real
quick does it yeah doesn't it does it
yep they're a hundred of hundred not a
smooth animation but the point is a plus
Safari not so much but it's it's
significantly faster just blows it out
of the water it's so much faster than
any other internet browser I've ever
used
so obviously while I'm using screen
recording software at the same time and
uploading videos and working my CPU
let's see this ready real quick I've got
a hundred processes running in Vista
right now so obviously not the best
performance but hey I've got the
connections running it's good it's it's
Safari it works in I I'm gonna have to
recommend it anyone's looking for good
freeware Signet now there's a lot of
people using Firefox and I admit Firefox
is pretty sweet at the Firefox preloader
so it loads just a few seconds faster I
was there was an opera preloader Safari
does not need a preloader because it is
that fast
oh there's liters Adams I've got a lot
of crap add-ons for it so the progress
bar like Safari I can change the color
of it I mean it's it's cool you know see
change it to blue so now whenever I load
a web page like YouTube Hey look at the
top you know you know there's just
add-ons make fire box more favorable
I guess in the overall market but I use
Safari as my main browser because of
pure speed so watching I hope you found
this tutorial helpful peace out
you